inciso b escribe los primeros cuatro
términos no nulos de la serie de taylor
para el coseno dx alrededor de x0 y
además usa esta serie y la serie del
seno de x cuadrada que encontraste en el
inciso a para escribir los primeros
cuatro términos no los de la serie de
taylor para la función f la función f
que teníamos acá arriba alrededor de x
igual a 0 bueno pues lo que necesitamos
primero es encontrar la serie de taylor
para el coseno de x entonces vamos a
hacerla una vez en la serie de taylor
como vimos en el inciso a era esta que
teníamos aquí era una serie que
aproximaba a la función original
entonces queremos los primeros cuatro
términos de la serie de taylor para el
coste de x entonces hdx es igual al
concepto de x una nueva función quién es
h evaluada en 0 pues es con seno de 0
que es 1 entonces h 0 es 1 ahora vamos a
derivar la h prima de x es igual a la
derivada del coseno que es igual al
menos seno de x y darse cuenta que es lo
mismo que del inciso anterior solamente
que
una derivada aunque de todas maneras lo
voy a hacer con calma para no perdernos
h prima evaluada en cero pues es igual
hace 900 pues entonces es 0 a 10 y prima
de x quien es pues es la derivada del
menú seno de x que es el menos coseno de
x la derivada del seno 50 x menos es
menos coseno de x y esta segunda
derivada evaluada en 0 es lo mismo que
el seno de cero es uno por menos me
queda menos uno menos uno ahora vamos a
sacar la tercera derivada la tercera
derivada de x es igual a la derivada del
- coseno de x que es el seno de x
positivo el seno de x y xi le evaluamos
la tercera derivada en cero pues me
quedase no de cero que es cero muy bien
y se dan cuenta a partir de aquí las
derivadas se van a empezar a repetir la
derivada del seno es el coseno por lo
tanto va a pasar lo mismo que me decís o
anterior lo voy a poner aquí no mejor
acá entonces la cuarta derivada de x va
a ser igual a la derivada del seno de x
pero si nosotros evaluamos en cero
1 la derivada del seno de x es el coseno
de x evaluada en 0 nos da 1 entonces h
de 0 es lo mismo que h 4a de 0 y es lo
mismo para la quinta derivada evaluada
en 0 va a dar 0 y la sexta derivada
evaluada en 0 me va a dar menos 1 y la
séptima derivada evaluada en 0 me va a
dar 0 y las siguientes derivadas se van
a seguir repitiendo es decir las
derivadas sucesivas del coseno de x
forman un ciclo son cíclicas muy bien
entonces hasta aquí vamos bien pero yo
lo que quiero son los primeros cuatro
términos no nulos entonces vamos a
encontrar los h de 0 en 1h mi primer 0
es nulo la derivada cuarta evaluado en
ceros no nula y la derivada sexta
evaluada en 0 también es no nula
entonces la aproximación en sede de
taylor de los primeros 4 términos no
nulos del coseno de x quien va a ser
pues bueno primero es h en cero pero h
en cero es uno entonces solamente
ponemos uno
es uno solo recuerda no confundirse en
hdx y fx fx lo pusimos en nuestra
fórmula del polinomio de taylor pero
aquí estamos utilizando a hdx entonces
vamos a seguirle h prima evaluada en 0
es 0 entonces pues este término se va no
es necesario ponerlo a hb prima evaluada
en ceros menos uno por equis cuadrada
entre dos factorial pues me queda menos
x cuadrado entre 2 factoriales y a esto
hay que sumarle la tercera derivada pero
la tercera derivada de evaluado en cero
es cero entonces se va la cuarta
derivada es 1 entonces más 1 por bueno
necesario poner el 1 es x 4 entre 4
factorial y después la quinta derivada
de verdad en 00 y la sexta derivada de
igualdad en cero es menos 1 entonces - x
sexta entre 6 factoriales y cuando esto
ya encontramos la primera parte del
inciso p de este problema por lo tanto
vamos una vez a ver la segunda parte de
este inciso b que decía
usa la usa la serie esta serie y la
serie que encontramos en situada para
seno de x cuadrada que es hasta que
tenemos aquí de hecho la simplificamos
un poco era esta que teníamos acá
entonces le voy a atrapar usa nuestra
aproximación para el corte no de x para
el seno de x elevado al cuadrado para
encontrar los primeros cuatro términos
de la serie de taylor que aproxima a fx
alrededor de x igual a cero ésta fx
entonces vamos a aumentarle para acá
antes de que se nos olvide fx es igual
al seno de x elevado al cuadrado más el
coseno de x y bueno queremos los
primeros cuatro términos no nulos de la
serie de taylor que aproximen a efe de x
por lo tanto fx es aproximadamente que
bueno además si se utiliza las
aproximaciones para el seno de x elevado
al cuadrado más el concepto de x
entonces vamos a recordar la
aproximación para el coste no de x era
ésta que tenemos aquí y la del seno de
que es elevada al cuadrado es ésta que
tenemos hasta acá por lo tanto la
aproximación de fx
pues es uno que es el término más
pequeño de la aproximación de coseno de
x ya su vez de seno de x elevado al
cuadrado es el término más pequeño y
después el término que le sigue va a ser
x cuadrada pero que es cuadrado aparecen
los dos aparece tanto en la aproximación
del concepto de x como la aproximación
del seno de ex cuadrada por lo tanto se
me ocurre mejor hacerlo de esta manera
quien era el seno de x al cuadrado su
aproximación en serie de taylor pues es
x cuadrado menos x está entre 3
factorial más a esto hay que sumarle a
10 x a la 10 entre 5 factorial menos x a
la 14 entre 7 factorial los voy a poner
todos juntos y después vamos a agrupar
términos semejantes y bueno a esto hay
que aumentarle a la aproximación del
coseno de x que genera era este de aquí
entonces más 1 - x cuadrada entre 2
factoriales más x cuarta entre 4
factorial menos equis extra entre 6
factoriales y bueno ya con esto tenemos
los primeros cuatro términos de la
aproximación de seno de x cuadrado
y tenemos los cuatros nuevos términos de
aproximación del coche de x ahora lo que
quiero ellos los cuatro primeros
términos de la aproximación en serie de
taylor df de x por lo tanto quien va a
ser como queremos solamente los cuatro
primeros términos de la aproximación de
fx no voy a tomar el primer término más
pequeño de todos los términos que
tenemos acá arriba que es 1 y después a
esto le aumentamos pues no hay nada con
x entonces que fijarnos lo que hay con x
cuadrada que es este de aquí y este de
canto le voy a poner más x cuadrada que
es este de aquí y a esto hay que
restarle x cuadrada entre 2 factoriales
que es lo mismo que x cuadrada entre
todos porque 2 factoriales 2 entonces
menos un medio de x cuadrada bien ya
todo esto hay que aumentar lo que hay de
x cúbica pero no hay nada de x cúbica
entonces hay que aumentarle lo que sigue
no hay nada de equis cúbica entonces x
4x cuarta es lo que el exponente que
sigue y solamente está este término de
aquí por lo tanto vamos a aumentarse lo
más x cuarta entre 4 factorial
x cuarta entre 4 factorial ahora vamos a
buscar x quintas en nuestra en nuestra
aproximación que tenemos acá arriba en
todos los términos que tenemos acá
arriba no hay nada con x quinta entonces
pues no ponemos nada con x quinta y sin
embargo si hay con x sexta que es este
de aquí y este de acá entonces ambos son
negativos por lo tanto voy a poner un
signo de menos paréntesis quien pues x
sexta entre 3 factorial ya éstos le
tengo que sumar x sexta entre 6
factorial porque acabo de factorizar el
menos menos x x está en 3 factoriales es
menos x 63 factorial y menos por x sexta
entre 6 factoriales menos x está en 36
factorial
y bueno ahora sí ya tenemos los cuatro
primeros términos de la aproximación de
fx entonces vamos a simplificar es uno
más
x cuadrada menos un medio de ecuador a
da pues es un medio de x cuadrada eso
está muy fácil x cuadrada entre 2 ya
esto le voy a aumentar a x 4 entre 4
factorial esto lo voy a dejar así para
más problemas ya esto le tenemos que
restar x sexta entre 3 factorial en + x
está entre 6 factorial pero bueno lo que
tenemos que hacer es simplificar este
término de aquí bueno 3 factorial lo
dejamos y se es factor ya es lo mismo
que 3 factorial por 4 por 5 por 6 4 por
ciento 20 por 620 entonces esto es lo
mismo que 120 por 3 factorial y bueno
como quiero poner aquí la respuesta
correcta entonces voy a tratar de
simplificar y sacar el mínimo común
múltiplo acá arriba entonces mejor aquí
arriba lo voy a poner todo
como simplificó esto pues me queda x
sexta entre tres factorial voy a
multiplicarlo todo tanto arriba como
abajo por cuatro por cinco por seis
entonces me queda x extra entre tres
factorial por cuatro por cinco por seis
y arriba me voy a poner 120 bien ya esto
hay que agregarle este todo esto de aquí
abajo es multifactorial entonces voy a
poner 6 factorial ya esto le voy a
agregar x sexta entre 6 factorial ya sea
que el mínimo común múltiplo queda 6
factorial y esto es ni más ni menos que
121 x sexta entre 6 factoriales y bueno
por este - que tenía aquí me queda menos
121 x sexta entre 6 factorial y perfecto
hemos acabado ya encontramos los cuatro
primeros términos no nulos de la serie
de taylor que aproxima a la función f x